vous êtes moi je suis désolé
c'est complètement nstt des stores qui
sont masculins la des sports qui sont
féminins voir une femme danse et c'est
très joli voir une fois de jouer au
football c'est moche et joseph yam et
pouvoir les voir une femme sur un vélo
c'est magique c'est mon nouveau ça
n'engage que moi curé savoir que les
oatei plus jolie sera venu je pense
qu'il faut savoir si cet aspect
extrêmement difficile moi j'aime trop
les femmes pour les voir sur scène c'est
mon prêt de gers on aime on ne peut pas
dire maintenant ses tarifs l'arraché sur
un vélo on
ne peut pas dire ce qu'on aime les
femmes quand on ne respecte pas leurs
aspirations et toute façon il faut
respecter leur exiguïté bon on s'exprime
sur un vélo on s'exprime dans le sport
il n'y a pas de sport qui conviennent
mieux à la diffamation
le sport doit avoir un côté esthétique
quand on enlève le côté esthétique du
sport il y perd 50% vous vous êtes moshi
désolé
s'attaquer directement jannier ou
animaux natation général le cyclisme
féminin je crois que je regarderai si le
risque d une 1 le jour où elles mettront
des maillots un peu plus jolie des
cuissards quelques jolis et des
chaussures du linge aux enseignants du
monde sur piste avec ce matériel
performant que j'avais j'avais tout une
image totalement moderne d'ici je les
jouais je crois que j'ai beaucoup
apporté aux cyclistes
oui attend mieux les
records du monde qui sont vraiment je
pense esthétiquement parlant avec le
casque le vélo les lunettes tout je
pense que c'est très beau et éthiquement
tard je trouve que c'est pas un sport
que l'esthétique est entre mille je
comprends qu'on a envie de faire du vélo
quand on est une femme mais moi je
préfère prendre dans l'air
ce qui coule
c'est une question d'esthétique c'est
pas très joli à bord j'aime pas avoir
les mystères du fait du vélo à moteur
je ne condamne pas le cyclisme féminin
si elles ont envie de le faire qu'elle
le fasse chez moi ça ne m'intéresse pas
alors vous avez répondre quoi janeiro je
suis frappé quand j ai répondu que je
pense que quelqu'un qui est ouvert
d'esprit qui doit lé qui se doit d'être
ouverts d'esprit va s'intéresser un
petit peu à tout
devant un petit peu connaître
donc je perds m'a dit ça m'intéresse pas
donc je m'y intéresser moi je trouve que
tout fait 300 km et que van sant dans
l'espace urbain c'est intéressant je
suis bien obligé de choses jeannie longo
est le maillot jaune pas vous